Pam J hey I'm Kevin and today we're
gonna be drying whatever the internet
tells us so this is a replay of a
previously recorded live stream the chat
on the live stream will be telling us
what to draw as embodied by the voice of
our producer Matt Matt we're gonna start
throwing suggestions at you okay if
something grab it if you grab for
something if something grabbed my
attention drop it drop it drop oh I
should be a town crier you should Lexie
Borja don't know how to pronounce it
dinosaurs in burlesque outfits cat on a
boards gate boarding on an alligator not
sure how that one works okay we got a
teenager learning to use an element of
your choosing this is just avatar that's
the log line of Avatar The Last
Airbender that they brought in Jackie as
the cat you take that back whoever said
that Jackie as a squirrel you take that
back we got a reverse centaur a reverse
Center so like horse top human person
bottom Oh Cthulhu working his summer job
Cthulhu working a summer job I'm gonna
look at what casue looks like I didn't
tell you that yeah I think you could do
that really cute it was kind of scary
I'm gonna draw this you can draw a
Cthulhu summer job food and working a
summer job okay what job should could do
have I was thinking of just a simple
cashier Oh Kevin as a squirrel Kevin as
a squirrel now that's a suggestion I can
get behind
alright I'll do me as a squirrel Oh a
little shade in the chat Barbara he says
Kevin will do him anyways Oh Barbara V
thanks my mom mom is that really gets my
mom mom what the hell I guarantee you
Barbara V is my mom I love Kevin's mom
oh I got I got a lot more jobs in
essence if you need one you think you
get it give it to me I'm just gonna get
lifeguard
we got swim instructor we got ice cream
parlor don't ice cream parlor people
come with wool hats yep
oh if you look up ice cream parlor
outfit you just get a lot of
uncomfortably sexy Halloween costumes
Jackie what do you know about the who
live octopus baby he's an octopus baby
baby hey Matt are there any questions in
the chat for us ask me a question I
probably won't answer it but maybe I
will black sheep in suggests what those
you guys favorite cartoons you go first
I have to think about it my current
favorite cartoon is Bob's Burgers Bob's
Burgers is amazing yes but I would say
my favorite cartoon of all time would
probably be freakazoid
you remember freakazoid well I mean I
know from the 90s
I know freakazoid but you know him I do
know personally yes I went to high
school with that get out yeah
is he cool no that's a bummer it's a
bummer you know domi your yours what's
your favorite cartoon I don't know
there's one it's my favorite but I think
when I was a kid the most I've ever
watched of a cartoon it's probably
Powerpuff Girls I was gonna guess it was
some type of anime like Sailor Moon or I
guess if oh if we're talking anime as
well
Sailor Moon over Naruto yeah cuz Naruto
came kind of later tiny Time Lord asked
if you were a superhero what would your
superpower be Wow okay what would be
your superpower yours would be being a
squirrel apparently what do you think I
would have 700 are we gonna do it for
each other let's do it for each other I
think it would get more interesting
results otherwise I'm gonna say
something stupid like I wish I could
teleport so I don't have to walk anymore
well that's actually kind of what I was
gonna say for you next question how do
you feel about a SuperSpeed that's
pretty cool I think I would love to just
flex on people for being really fast so
that's what I would choose for you what
would you choose for me
the power to change someone's mind like
Inception no just like a yes or no
decision yeah do you want to go get ice
cream wait wait wait let's try it out do
you want to go get ice cream yes I don't
even like ice cream
you know like ice cream oh yeah I hate
all things that are fun how's it going
coming it's going pretty good I'm lining
I've got a good time learning as well I
got a great question from Ruby artwork
love you Ruby artwork how do you color
faster are there any tips and tricks
that you have to color and eye drawing
faster I'll take this one
one thing that I've started to do here
on draw off learning from Jackie is to
simply duplicate my line art layer and
use the paint bucket tool in order to
fill it in now in my world of print
media that is not a good way to do it
because you want to do what's called
trapping and I'm not gonna bore you with
what trapping is but for screen art it's
perfectly acceptable and it's a much
quicker way to to color asami yuzawa
love nurse asks if you could have
contributed to any cartoon or anime I'm
assuming in history what would it be it
was pretty good Wow that is a great
question
spirited away I wish I made that
single-handed just by yourself by myself
I wish I worked on it but I debt I
definitely was born the year it came out
I'm gonna go with freakazoid again
freakazoid yeah love that guy it really
informed my sense of humor
what color is cocoon what does a chat
think what color should Cthulhu be so I
am then what flavor of ice cream should
this be oh yeah very important
and should it have toppings if so what
kind sprinkles rainbow sprinkles I mean
he's like a horrifying demon wants like
blood on it no no I'm Bo sprinkles I
mean blood just hits the spot in a
different kind of way hot pink seems to
be on the top of the list and mint
chocolate chip is the most popular
flavor guys are weird
Jackie do you like drawing live on the
internet it has no positive or negative
effects
you are completely neutral about it I
have there's just no emotion attached
there's no emotions attached to a lot of
things you do huh yeah I think so are
you dead sidetracked a little bit huh if
you look into my eyes if you look
closely if you if you look take off my
shoes oh geez okay look closely into my
eyes you can see that there is no more
happiness or joy only suffering okay
Jackie you're making the Internet
feel really uncomfortable I love this
question from Andrew Blissett Andrew
beset hit us with it who is your first
cartoon crush oh my god Jackie who was
your first card Yugi from Yugi seriously
yes
oh boy not Yugi but when you geek
becomes cool because he's using the
pyramid whatever yeah I don't really
remember the details yeah but I was like
wow
what a guy that Yugi I also sorry
everybody I really like Gary from
Pokemon Gary Gary is like who's Harry oh
really
yeah oh you like the bad boy yeah I like
the bad ones oh he's not bad he's a he's
a good guy yeah yeah but he's cool like
a bad guy I'm gonna give her a really
lame answer and a very like white boy
answer Jessica Rabbit yep god I hate
this I'm sorry I am done I am also done
I have finished how do you think you did
I think I did wonderfully do you think
you did the internet proud do you guys
like my drawing a lot of knows my career
is over YouTube said
I can't draw that was just a joke
Oh see Matt hesitated boy Matt doesn't
like my drawing I think it's great he
says no I do what do you think you did
Kevin well it definitely looks like me
as a squirrel you know what Jackie they
say draw what you know and I know me you
know you and I know squirrels and you
know a squirrel I don't know screw I
actually have not seen many squirrels I
had to pull up a reference for squirrels
because I don't know what squirrels look
like off the top of my head it's really
really funny why draw squirrel from
memory right now you got 30 seconds
ACORN okay well we'll see yeah we'll see
I'll put him he's the one getting the
ice cream
[Music]
what is that noise
uncomfortable it's good it's just scary
I like making you uncomfortable with my
drawings yours is adorable Thanks it's
you know what when the internet
suggested it I had a mental image in my
head and this is pretty much what I saw
I drew the squirrel do you like the
squirrel yeah your squirrel is better
than mine you did in like 30 seconds
congratulations is that what you want to
hear yeah I just wanted to hear that I'm
better than you in every way and that I
am a perfect and flawless human being
and I can draw literally anything and
everything without looking up reference
was this fun would you've done this yeah
that was really fun let's do that again
I did I'd liked a lot of the suggestions
but the fact that I could only pick one
made it made me picky we'll have to do
it again right yeah if you guys want
more live streams let's get some eyes in
the chat everyone just starts screaming
let's get some screams in the channel I
get some screams can we get some
blood-curdling screams like murderous
screams in the chat like you are dying
of murder in the chat in the chat please
why you always gotta make it weird at
the end
[Music]